monsieur Santoul
ça arrive
vous voyez oui c'est arrivé donc merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur du soft
nous espérons pas beaucoup de votre
sincérité de votre franchise
néanmoins beaucoup de choses à redire
en 2017 il y avait 550 morts dans des
accidents du travail dans ce pays en
2018 il y en avait 562 en 2019 il y en a
eu 733 et je ne compte pas les accidents
de la route évidemment ce qui signifie
qu'entre 2017 et 2019 c'est 33%
d'accidents du travail causant la mort
en plus donc vous ne pouvez pas arriver
ici et me dire que la suppression des
CHSCT n'a eu aucun effet ce sont 150
orphelins de veuve en plus et vous avez
la responsabilité de ses choix
politiques vous êtes un imposteur et un
assassin
chers collègues alors
[Applaudissements]
chers collègues ne hurle pas j'ai
entendu ne hurlez pas je suspente deux
minutes
[Applaudissements]
chers collègues la séance est reprise
ensuite
dans le cas mais la sérénité et il n'y a
que moi qui est la parole pour l'instant
je pense que nous ce que nous avons
traversé devrait nous inciter à être un
peu humble et j'espère calme au moins
jusqu'à la fin de cette séance mais j'ai
des demandes de rappel aux règlements je
vais y donner évidemment accès c'est la
présidente berger pour le groupe
Renaissance qui va s'exprimer en premier
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le Président je le dis
très calmement mais je dis très
fermement il est inacceptable il
n'envisageable que l'on continue dans
ces escalade verbales on ne peut en
aucun cas traiter le ministre Olivier du
soft d'assassin dans l'enceinte de cette
hémicycle
monsieur le
monsieur le Président je voudrais
ajouter trois choses la première c'est
qu'évidemment je crois que l'assemblée
dans sa quasi unanimité vient d'apporter
au ministre on peint un soutien sur la
réforme qu'il porte mais un soutien
humain qui doit poser des limites à ce
qui est acceptable et ce qui est
inacceptable j'espère que chaque
président de groupe pourra se
positionner j'espère que chaque
président de groupe de la nupes pourra
se positionner pour dire clairement
qu'évidemment il se désolidarise tes
propos qui ont été tenus et qu'ils ne
peuvent en aucun cas les reprendre à
leur compte ou laisser penser qu'il
laisserait passer de telles propos
la deuxième chose
c'est que j'espère qu'évidemment des
excuses claires et sincères seront
présentées mais vous savez pas des
excuses je m'excuse mais non des excuses
point barre je pense que c'est la
moindre des choses
et enfin évidemment
nous nous souhaitons le débat nous
l'avons dit nous ne voulons pas bloquer
cette séance nous ne voulons pas bloquer
le débat nous ne demandons pas donc une
convocation immédiate du bureau de
l'Assemblée mais nous demandons à ce que
ce sujet lors du prochain Bureau de
l'Assemblée puisse être évidemment
évoqué parce qu'à la fin ce que nous
voulons c'est débattre et c'est voter je
vous remercie
merci madame la Présidente je demande de
paroles le président Vallot qui
souhaitait la parole pour le groupe
socialiste merci
allez-y président merci monsieur le
président
je voudrais dire que ce dont nous avons
envie ici c'est de parler de la réforme
des retraites et d'un certain nombre des
sujets que nous avons commencé à aborder
notamment la pension minimale à 1200
euros nous avons bien les questions à
poser au ministre pour apporter des
éclaircissements aux Français je
voudrais dire aussi qu'il faut ici
défendre avec conviction avec passion
parfois avec colère ce à quoi l'on croit
mais jamais avec des mots qui peuvent
blesser ou heurter et j'en appelle à la
sérénité et à la maîtrise de chacune et
de chacun mais ça vaut pour nous toutes
et tous que chacun est le désir
désormais de dire ce à quoi il croit de
combattre comme nous le ferons avec
énergie détermination conviction cette
réforme inique et que nous en restions à
ce combat là
merci monsieur le Président la
présidente châtelain
les présidents de groupe la présidente
Chatelain après je demanderai il y aura
une demande de prise de parole de
Monsieur saint tout le jeu lui donnerai
pour l'instant ce sont les présidents de
groupe ou leurs représentants
ce débat est attendu et regardez par des
centaines de milliers voire des millions
de Français ils attendent de nous que
nous défendons nos convictions chacun
d'entre nous sans doute s'ils
comprennent parfois la colère parfois
l'émotion mais ils attendent toujours
qu'on le fasse avec dignité avec rigueur
et dans le respect à partir de là les
mots ont un sens et ne peuvent pas dans
cette hémicycle est utilisé à la légère
[Applaudissements]
car je suis persuadé en tout cas nous
partageons la conviction que oui
l'impact de cette réforme mais ça doit
être le contenu de nos débats sera
néfaste sera dangereuse mais c'est un
combat qu'on doit d'avoir sur nos idées
et je suis persuadée que nous pouvons
passer au vote et que nous pouvons
gagner sur l'impact de cette réforme en
tant que tel que les Français
comprennent
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur nez
je l'aime
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le Président vous savez
avec mon groupe nous ne sont pas nous ne
sommes pas d'accord sur tout ce que fait
le gouvernement néanmoins nous assistons
depuis 10 jours maintenant au concours
Les Pins de l'image de la parole la plus
violente possible il y a une escalade
qui devient insupportable nous nous
donnons une image pathétique aux
françaises et aux Français qui nous
regardent qui suivent les débats et qui
vont être impactés par cette réforme des
retraites
même si nous ne sommes pas d'accord le
minimum de respect doit être en place
dans cette émission
nous faisons des leçons de morale
chacune chacun à nos offres nous allons
chacun chacune dans les écoles en
expliquant ce que sont nos institutions
en expliquant comment nous devons nous
comporter encore une fois l'image que
nous renvoyons est intolérable et
monsieur le Président j'espère que c'est
la dernière fois que nous aurons à subir
une suspension de séance due à des
propos de cette violence et je voulais
apporter tout mon soutien bien entendu
au ministre du secteur
merci
président Mattei
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le Président on vient
vivre un moment particulièrement
dur avec ces mots qui ont été prononcés
par notre collègue alors qu'entre
d'Olivier du socle et on nous apporte
total soutien humain amical et on
reconnaît
sa détermination
des mots comme assassins ont été
prononcés dans ce dans cette émission
c'est pas tolérable je me demande où
vais s'arrêter cette dérive verbale il
faut vraiment que ça s'arrête nous
devons débattre nous respecter
mutuellement mais en aucune manière
prononcer des termes aussi graves dans
cette émission qui est le réceptacle de
notre démocratie
président Chassaigne
sur le Président chers collègues
au nom des députés du groupe la gauche
démocratique je tiens à dire à quel
point nous sommes choqués par les propos
qui ont été tenus et j'ajouterai
et j'ajouterai
et j'ajouterai à titre peut-être plus
personnel
que je me sens blessé
même humilié je le dis
je le dis tenir de tels propos est
absolument inacceptable nous sommes ici
nous sommes ici pour nous combattre
nous sommes ici
pour opposer des arguments
pour porter une parole sans concession
n'est jamais je dis bien jamais nos
débats nos arguments ne doivent dériver
avec des insultes qui sont portés contre
des marques de cette assemblée et contre
des membres du gouvernement le débat
démocratique c'est un échange d'idées
c'est pas un échange d'insultes
continuons à nous affronter sans
concession
cinq concessions sans tout cas ce que
porte le goût de la gauche de vos
[Applaudissements]
présidente Le Pen
ché
au débat je pense que l'immense majorité
de cette hémicycle a ressenti exactement
la même chose mais ça fait une semaine
que dure cette escalade verbale qui je
crois atteint peut-être aujourd'hui son
apogée je voudrais tout de même rappeler
qu'il y a énormément d'arguments à
échanger sur cette réforme des retraites
c'est pas les arguments qui manquent et
on sait très bien que nous avons des
oppositions très fortes et très
profondes mais que si on pouvait se
rappeler juste une chose c'est qu'en
politique on n'a pas d'ennemis on a des
adversaires et bien on éviterait d'en
arriver à de telles extrémités
évidemment l'ensemble de mon groupe
souhaite apporter son soutien à Olivier
du soft ce qui a été très certainement
marqué par cette injure très grave et
très lourde
président marlex
merci monsieur le Président au nom de
députés du groupe de républicains je
voudrais d'abord dire au ministre du
stop notre notre soutien notre
solidarité face aux propos qu'il vient
de qui vient de subir il peut y avoir
dans notre émission de la passion il
peut y avoir de l'émotion mais rien ne
justifie l'insulte rien ne justifie les
injures et rien ne justifie ce qui
pourrait ressembler à de la violence
il est inacceptable il est totalement
inacceptable que ce qui se dit dans
notre hémicycle ce qui se passe dans
notre hémicycle puisse être interprété à
l'extérieur comme une incitation à la
haine comme une incitation à la violence
et donc monsieur le monsieur le
Président je crois que les mots que nous
avons entendus appellent très clairement
des excuses de la part de notre collègue
mais ça ne peut pas suffire ça appelle
aussi évidemment une sanction dans le
cadre du pouvoir de police qui est qui
est le vôtre monsieur le monsieur le
président
Marc Angeli
merci monsieur le président
nous avons à peine débuté
cet après-midi et déjà une suspension de
séance avec la nécessité pour chacun des
présidents de groupe à s'exprimer tout
d'abord je voudrais me tourner vers
monsieur le ministre et lui dire à mon
tour mon soutien et celui du groupe que
je préside tant sur le plan humain que
sur le plan politique
mes chers collègues je l'ai déjà eu
l'occasion de dire la semaine dernière
et dans cette hémicycle et également
lorsque nous nous sommes réunis en
bureau suite à l'incident qui nous a
fait perdre beaucoup de temps
vos idées sont respectables votre combat
est respectable même si ne pas partager
de part et d'autre de cette hémicycle
mais de grâce
réfléchissez au poids des mots
réfléchissez à ce qui est ressenti par
les Français en dehors de cette émission
ne peut pas impunément traité un
ministre un élu un homme une femme
d'assassin parce qu'on n'est pas
d'accord avec lui sur la réforme des
retraites
alors mon cher collègue je ne sais pas
ce que vous allez faire
c'est à votre conscience et à votre
coeur de parler comme vous le faites
lorsque vous exprimez contre cette
réforme mais je le dis dans l'intérêt de
celles et de ce que vous défendez dans
l'intérêt des idées qui sont les vôtres
cessons c'est son employé ces termes
redonnant de l'honneur de la clarté et
de la hauteur à nos débats
merci je proposais un autre collègue de
prendre la parole
dans le silence voilà on s'écoute merci
monsieur le président
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues je souscris en réalité
pleinement aux propos du président Marc
angélique
j'ai eu il y a quelques instants à ce
micro des mots que l'émotion et
l'emportement
m'ont fait mal choisi et qui sont
déplacés je souhaite évidemment les
retirer et adresser des excuses
publiques au ministre et je me tiens à
sa disposition pour avoir un échange
plus personnel et lui présenter à
nouveau mes excuses je crois
effectivement que nous avons ici une
responsabilité qui est de mener un débat
clair argumenté je ne suis pas de ceux
qui se dérobent à la polémique et ceux
d'entre vous qui me connaissent et qui
ont eu l'occasion d'échanger plus
directement avec moi le savent je ne
suis pas non plus de ceux qui
choisissent la mauvaise foi quand je
commets une erreur je suis prêt à le
faire savoir j'ai commis une erreur et
j'en demande donc le d'être excusé de ça
la fatigue encore une fois l'émotion
l'emportement d'autres raisons plus
personnelles me font avoir à coeur cette
question des morts du travail
elle a été extrêmement importante
évidemment je vous demande donc de
recevoir ces excuses monsieur le
ministre et comme je viens de vous le
dire je suis à votre disposition pour
avoir une discussion plus personnelle
monsieur le ministre ne vous écoutons
[Applaudissements]
merci Michel
merci merci Monsieur Président Mesdames
et Messieurs les Députés Mesdames et
Messieurs les Présidents de groupe
d'abord je voudrais remercier les
présidents de groupe qui sont exprimés
pour condamner les mots qui ont été
prononcés et les remercie pour leur
soutien leur solidarité je sais que
cette expression n'emporte pas ni une
adhésion ni un soutien à la réforme que
je présente devant vous je pars je
considère que la participe de la volonté
du maintien d'un climat républicain dans
cette hémistique et en cela je vous en
suis particulièrement reconnaissant
monsieur le Président j'ai un immense
honneur c'est celui de siéger dans cette
hémistique depuis 2007 j'ai été élu
quatre fois par les habitants de mon
département j'ai été dans l'opposition
j'étais dans la majorité j'ai l'immense
honneur de participer au gouvernement et
de défendre semaine après semaine des
projets de loi des textes de répondre
aux questions des parlementaires devant
vous et j'essaie de le faire de mon
mieux j'ai toujours considéré
au plus profond de moi que la violence
qu'elle soit physique verbale symbolique
n'avait aucune place dans la vie
politique je partage ce qu'on dit un
certain nombre de présidents je pense
notamment à ce que dit le prison de
richasaigne aussi les gens
le président siège depuis peut-être plus
longtemps que moi mais je siège depuis
que je siège je n'ai côtoyé les mots
peuvent être vifs les arguments peuvent
être assez serrés la contestation
peut-être très forte et finalement les
argumentations peuvent parfois être
extrêmement difficiles et soutenu c'est
le sel de la démocratie je dois dire
qu'en réalité je préfère mille fois les
débats font les plus ardues des débats
qui vous amènent dans votre tranchement
et qui vous permettent finalement
d'aller au fond des sujets parfois même
de convaincre vos interlocuteurs ou à
défauts d'être convaincus par eux je
préfère mille fois ça à tout autre
emportements et à toute autre excès
la seule chose qui compte pour moi à
cette heure c'est que la réforme puisse
être examinée et que nous puissions
aller au fond des choses et au fond des
sujets c'est la seule chose qui me
concerne c'est la seule chose qui me
préoccupe
depuis le député j'entends vous excuses
elles ont le mérite d'être présenté
et elles permettent au débat de se
poursuivre
depuis une dizaine de jours dans
plusieurs de vos interventions vous avez
eu à mon égard entre 10 et 12
qualificatifs que je peux considérer
comme insultant dont un qui a atteint le
paroxysme de l'insulte
j'entends vos excuses mais vous
comprendrez qu'à traiter d'assassin de
ce pardonne pas par contre ces excuses
ont émérite c'est qu'elles permettent
aux débattre continuer et c'est mon seul
souhait
[Applaudissements]
bien chers collègues en vertu de
l'article 71 alinéa 3 je prononce à
l'encontre de collection Toul un rappel
à l'ordre avec inscription au
procès-verbal la présidente de notre
assemblée vera les suites qu'elle
souhaite donner en ce qui concerne la
convocation éventuelle de notre collègue
devant le bureau le prochain Bureau de
l'Assemblée nationale et nous allons
reprendre la séance